well i'm very excited you guys i have my
first
stand-up date i know esther you had
yours i'm going to the house of comedy
in minnesota
and that's going to be may 6-9 so it's a
one show on thursday two friday to
saturday
and one on sunday and i am so excited to
get back on stage so get your tickets
i'm gonna post on my instagram
do you know that santino and bobby are
trying to pit you
against my poor little niece i have
gotten so
many messages in the last week
that your niece is talking [ __ ] about me
no she's not
that your niece wants to fight me no
they're just making it up so you'll
think you know jules jules is like
are they recording of course okay hang
on she's not going to pick up tell him
to pick up
jules i have a question for you are you
guys recording
yeah um do you is it true that you want
to fight esther
yeah can i tell oh my god they're
holding a gun to her head right now
oh hang on hang on here's i'm going to
pass you to esther hang on hi
jules um
[Music]
so the past few days i have gotten
some would say hundreds of messages from
people
saying that you want to fight me and
that you've been
talking smack about me but i feel like
you and i
we've always really gotten along eye to
eye because she's a child
you know i i know there was that one
time i needed you to move the car
um yeah i feel like we've always had a
good chemistry
and just a mutual respect i just wanted
to see like what's going on
oh it's steven bobby and um andrew's
fault they want
they want us to fight so i feel like i
need to fight you
why why do they want us to fight
because they said that i would win
and then
they said that you would win and what
they said that you were weak
oh yeah how much do you weigh
um i'm 115. oh really
she'll crush it yeah but you're so
skinny
would you be mad if i was voting rooting
for her
first of all i'm not physically fighting
anyone you're not a lawyer president no
that's always gonna say you'll fight her
in
court um okay i'm gonna hand it over
to your aunt koloko because i don't
really know what else to say
i could just be very very clear about
this uh
this fight would make so much more money
than the jake paul fight
this would make do you want money or not
jules
now before you get cocky may i remind
you that i have seen you box
and it makes me ashamed to call you
family so
don't start fights you can't finish
because let me tell you something about
esther she'll file some paperwork
and she'll come get you she may walk out
of a barry's boot camp but she did walk
in
she is low-key if she puts hands on you
i
i mean you're you're my niece and all
but i might have my money on her so
prepare yourself okay
to have some really little bruises
well let me tell you what you don't know
about esther again
she's a [ __ ] ankle biter she's an
actual dog
from the age of four to five she she
thought she was an actual
dog so that's what you're up against so
think about it real
deep and hard okay okay i love you
bye-bye
i swear the poisonous [ __ ] that bobby
and santino put in that poor girl's head
yeah she shouldn't be around them
i blame the ginger
[Music]
can i say something semi-creepy yeah
okay
always the way you're dressed today is
like the exact way that i'm very
attracted to women when they're dressed
like this
like a boy you mean boyish like ripped
specifically
ripped jeans and like a casual like a
vintagey cool like basic top
and then long dark hair like
there's in your socks like it's there's
something very i think my real
the real men out there know what i'm
talking about this is a very sexy look
can i guess why you like the tears in
the jeans
why because they come up to your height
and it looks like you just started to
tear clothes off at the knee
i do have a tear right in my crotch like
this isn't irregular i still would have
had a jump up for that one
also i'd like to point out because i'm
sort of anti-super
torn jeans i'm not into like
pre-distressed jeans
huh i these jeans were ripped naturally
i've had them since i was
15 years old that's such a funny thing
to bring up i'm so jealous because i
[ __ ] read
a magazine article once it said halle
berry kept a jeep pair of jeans since
she was 15 so she could always know that
she fit into them
so then i was i read that when i was 15
i was like i'm going to save this pair
of jeans but now i can't find them so
it's like my goal
i have to find they're a toddler too
[Laughter]
i can't oh my god i want you guys to
actually
wear these jeans because they are so
soft but
so fragile at this point like any
movement that's
so sad though for me like by the way i
would bust them and then all of a sudden
the leg would be flapping open
and also when someone jeans are baggy on
one person and then the other person
puts them on and it's like
well i guess these pants aren't
traveling sisters
oh boy but the best is when a rip jean
has like a secretly sexy rip like how
you have so you can kind of see your
underwear like do you know the ones
where it's like right under
the butt cheeks i have a couple of those
that's me to me is sexier than lingerie
how do you well let's be real lingerie
has that ever been in your life
that was so weird it's too much too big
of a swing do you guys wear laundry
do you
darling maybe you should try to impress
bobby with some lingerie i love that
even your mom's like listen you've let
yourself go
you're going to lose this you're going
to lose this no and you know eric
griffin once told me something that i'll
never forget
and it pissed me off to no end which is
um maybe you should walk around the
house in more lacy things
[Applause]
griffin notoriously says the most
triggering annoying things like a man
could say
i once we did a pilot for a show where
we were gonna like
be uber drivers that were sent taking
people to like go get their
boyfriends back because i was like so it
was this idea that eric's like
this is going to sell and i'm like i
don't even know what the idea is it
makes sense that you and eric were cast
as uber driver
and also when are you two uber drivers
that's how bad we are we needed a helper
but we were like you know how to do
these like fake tests or like pretending
to drive
and i can't tell you how many times i
was genuinely screaming at him like
eric because he was like women are so
shallow i'm like my boyfriend is 350
pounds i'm shallow
it was so annoying i do like meanwhile
he has like a model girlfriend i'm like
oh worship i think that's what happened
i think
he looked at his his own model s perfect
looking girlfriend and then looked at me
and
he probably thought bobby's my best
friend
you could probably try a little bit
harder i think he was trying to help
bobby out but bobby well he doesn't know
that bobby doesn't like that
no it's weird that's a specific guy like
yeah
yeah lingerie is like hard because i
feel like i the way i picture it is
never the way i look in it
and it's so traumatic when you see
yourself and like though also if they're
super it just
it's lingerie in your size is literally
pedophilic i mean that's like
they don't have come in children's sizes
i like the idea that like
the garter like comes up to it here on
you
i have a i have a proposition you put
the crap
the crutches part over your head i have
a proposition
i think that we should work through our
lingerie trauma and we should have a
lingerie episode
okay okay so we bring our fave well we
bring
what we would never wear a type of
lingerie that we would never
wear in the bedroom do we get it for
each other no
no no you will bring me like titles
vaginalist nipple covers that's what
i'll bring you
wait can i can we also do a bathing suit
day because i have real
bathing suit trauma right can we do like
a bathing suit after can i get like
12 weeks no no we don't get to just
spring it off
i think that's the point yeah we just
spring it off and we love the bodywork
yes we'll spring it on
with a side bush everything you know
what i will recommend which i would do
is like
hi i don't need any recommendations from
you high waist
high waist high waist you know does not
look good on me at all
oh my god i promise you the barbie doll
because
no because you know how just like it
covers my like sick hard ass yeah it's
not good for me
it's not it makes me look even boxier
than i am
because if you know the the trend of
like the really high cut bikini yeah
and but it's kind of low in the front i
will show you guys i will prove it to
you that it's not my best look i look
better with low
lower writing even though i hate low
ride stuff my body looks better in lower
eyes i look good elongated right like
you don't yeah i would kill to look
better in low riding like i would have
you look cute in low riding you have
like you know what you have you have
like the belly like remember when
britney spear this is
again creepy but this was the world when
she did the first like hit me baby one
more time and she had like the little
bit of a belly
yeah you have like that thank you i i
have a little more but i will take the
compliment gracie i mean you are wearing
this high but you also had to fold it
over your confusing specimen thank you
she it doesn't quite fit but then it
also is too big we're talking about the
skirt
this they've figured it out okay wait
okay speaking of what eric griffin said
to you i have a question
why what is it with all of bobby's
friends
basically secretly being in love with
you i watched you on theo von's podcast
i love i love theovon i think he's hot
as [ __ ] i think
you do yes i think his energy is hot
like
i love that he just like loves women
like i feel that from him
but i want to know d is there
like any because okay if you didn't see
it theo is was like
coming on to kaleila hardcore was like
can i be second in line after bobby
and i i was dying to ask you like
because i feel like you're
like kind of not really responding fully
is there any world where what's your
my deal with the yeah i think that he's
um
catching a vibe i'm not and um
but i love him so deeply he's one of the
few comics that i've built a
relationship with over eight years and
you know like there there's a feeling of
like
familiar family like even though he's
from louisiana and i'm from the
philippines
there's like a kindred spirit there
that's undeniable alligators
right big lizards so he has alligators
but we have the real crocodiles the 25
footers that actually eat people
um so he loses there but theo lives in a
creative made up world yeah what do you
mean
he's always talking about someone flying
around in a bubble or something like
that was timmy
bubble timmy when i was a kid he didn't
say in a bubble he did say something
that was interesting which is like
uh he has um difficulty like speaking to
women or feeling like comfortable around
women so i propose that he is our first
male guest
yes yeah because i think we're the
perfect set of girls to
sort of just get that those you know
hash those feelings out
we will pull it all out of him i want to
and i just love him i have such a deep
love for him so
i think he'd be perfect what if he like
in his head is like editing this just to
be like i love him he's perfect
and that's how he falls asleep i guess
like worst case scenario because i
he posed that question you know i was
like okay gun to my head you know which
mail comic um when he said shop i was
like you do not understand
they're so they don't understand they
think they know what we want and they're
not correct wait so he asked you what
female comment what male 1 oh my god
you're such a lesbian it really is real
and i'm not making it up i'm not making
it up you saw it there
i'm not she's not forty and slit that's
what you say when it's a lesbian one
what is it
freudian slit what does that mean vagina
i miss george andres is like english is
my second language what are you saying
i did not understand that but now i do
you your brain is too much for this
world
okay but so did he asked you what male
comic you'd be into and what'd you say
i said i feel like i just put this poor
guy out every episode but it's jamar
neighbors that's my comment
that's my comedy crush wait do you know
what jamar did
jamar went to my jujitsu class which by
the way i haven't been to jiu jitsu in a
while and if you can tell
but uh by the bat wings but
i haven't been in quite a while um but
jamar
he went to my jiu jitsu class a day i
wasn't there he went with this girl
caroline that goes
and he wore like spandex and he put a
giant dildo in it
and then just wrestled with all them and
there's one black kid in the
in the class but like he came in like
i'm a black guy with a big black dick
and so no one was going to be like
excuse me black man could get your heart
bone from me
no but he just yeah he just had it the
whole time why did he do that
because he's a he's like the best kind
of troll because he's a version of bobby
i think that's why
like i'm into him he seems like he'd
have the bobby antics
what just because like he would do
whatever's wild yeah
i've never this is how many podcasts
have i said this on george
poor jamar i'm sure at this point he
feels the way i did in theo's podcast
when he posted after the first one what
did he pose he posted i'm never getting
on tiger belly again
right bobby would probably want to watch
let's be real you know i've kissed jamar
in a like i know in a you know like a
short film
that some random people were producing
and this was like you know 11 years ago
when we were all open makers
and he jamar walked me down the aisle
and i will say he did improvise the kiss
was it the ice cream aisle
i don't know why there was an aisle
buddy
oh my god no jamar are done no no it's
completely fine
but he like dipped me and then gave me a
big smooch
like brian scalaro did that though it
would be a different story that is
inappropriate to bring up wait is there
a story about brian no i just killed
someone that wasn't
as hot as jamar he's very hot but he's
not as hot
you would never know brian scalaro is
more my type probably
same me with me too oh my god brian
salar is going to be so hard in the damn
i need to remember that your dms are
better be closed because he's coming
if you and i i need to remember if you
and i ever have sexual chemistry i need
to take that as an insult
you like i need to remember that anytime
you look at me like a little
longingly that's not a good thing for me
i feel like if you
um had a camera follow esther and i
single hitting on men you'd be just
sorely disappointed at our choices
well they're probably very surprised
right because they don't they think
you're [ __ ] with them they're like
you're not
probably from her but from me i think
i'm pretty approachable i think guys are
like
not with these new looks now that pink
showed you where there
it is i heard that we're celebrating
something today
i think george has something planned for
us he doesn't want to just
throw cinco de mayo at us he wants us to
earn cinco de mayo
okay well this is our special cinco de
mayo episode oh
okay so we're we're calling this game
earn your sombrero
um you know we live in a in a world
where
um a lot of appropriation is happening
correct and we're not talking about my
earrings
we're not talking about annie's earrings
so instead of
celebrating mindlessly we're going to
earn
our right to celebrate cinco de mayo
together we have to get them right
together yes we're a team oh so we're a
team we're going to as a team answer
questions george poses for us
all right are we ready to earn our
sombreros guys yes
uh so question number one who is vicente
fernandez
he is well vicente is like san vicente
is he something to do with that no no
the street the famous street
in west l.a any takers he
um he came up with um
just for men he's the spokesman and the
he looks like an like an actor like a
businessman like he looks very
prominent he is very
he's a billionaire probably by now
so esther businessman annie billionaire
do you know who he is yes i do that's
[ __ ] chante
chante is a god from mexico chiente is
uh
vicente fernandez is a mexican-american
oh he's a mexican singer
and he has like all like he's like the
frank frank sinatra
and then yeah burt reynolds is playing
him or is that
like in the one in the red does that not
look like it's burt reynolds playing him
if you know there's a song by vicente
fernandez that could have been a great
name for our podcast
which is mujeres divinas which is like
divine women
oh all right so we got one let's uh
let's go with the next one wait hold on
that's one point for the team
yeah okay good we're one for one guys
name
three mexican iconoclasts i thought
o'connor class was a
like better like a motel what's an
iconoclast
someone who is for example i'll give one
frida kahlo
salma hayek i think she's an iconic
class yes
okay that's two two uh we've got two
from everybody else one
two like let's uh third i have i have an
answer
i have hernan cortes pancho villa
um that's four wait do you need three or
four
i always lose on at midnight like i
never i'm bad on the spot
but at midnight was pre-written oh my
god
the show's been canceled long enough i
think we can let the cat out of the bag
okay
they have [ __ ] writers they come in
you get their two hours early
everything's on a card in front of you i
still always lost
you didn't push the thing fast enough i
was psychotic i would like
um okay go ahead uh one more
kind of clash let's uh el chapo
he escaped jail through a hole in the
thing and then rode out on a motorcycle
remember
he escaped mexican prison if you escaped
prison i'm impressed
ladies today we are sponsored by magic
spoon
our favorite cereal uh i love magic
so much i'm so happy that they like us
we come in a variety pack and so do they
growing up cereal was one of the best
parts of being a kid but we all
pretty much gave it up because we
realized it was full of sugar and junk
and stuff that you really shouldn't have
been eating
and i know all of us are trying to cut
down on things like carbs sugar
unhealthy food
and then you start to feel like okay
well what can i eat that's where
magic spoon comes in you guys it's zero
grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain-free soy free
and gmo free i love that they have a
variety pack where you can get
cocoa fruity frosted and peanut butter
my favorite is fruity it's
incredible if you mix the cocoa with the
peanut butter it tastes exactly like
peanut butter cup
just fyi you guys can go to
magicspoon.com
bathgirls to grab a variety pack and try
it today and be sure to use our promo
code
bathgirls at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a hundred
percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com
bathgirls and use the cold bath girls to
save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode and thank you to our
listeners for checking out magic spoon
supporting
us and our sponsor
who did the mexicans fight on the fifth
of may
um their uh chihuahua that is a cinco de
mayo in uh
this one i don't know i don't know any
stuff like that spanish
i got this no they [ __ ] no texas it's a
franco-mexican war
the french the french yes okay uh
name three mexican musicians okay i got
it
uh number one mariachi guy number two
mariachi guy and number three
doesn't she look like she could be in a
little tele even in this outfit a little
telemundo
is gloria estefan oh she's cuban oh okay
so esther got one
crespo i have mana and i'm gonna add
anna gabriel who is like my icon
um there's a there's an easy one out
here who are
there's an easy one out here name the
song george which one
you said there's an easy one oh selena
oh
selena selena selena nomez no offense
yes yes selena's good i think we won
that one yes we got points in that
uh name five mexican foods okay
enchiladas
quesadilla tostada
uh tacos burritos nacho fries
chicken fries what betia what's that oh
maddie matheson just opened
iberia place here in l.a what's beer
yeah it's like a stew
but it's very very good and um i'm gonna
add sope
i love sope there's also um
the whole taco bell menu remember right
all right we're doing great guys we just
got a few more questions
did you say mountain dew bob all right
what is this soup that's like a grain
it's kind of bluish you put honey in it
you guys tell me in the comments i think
oatmeal
no it's not like oatmeal it's like blue
then like
it's like a mexican cream of wheat or
maybe it's spanish i used to
uh make it when i was a veteran that
sounds good and breakfast
and innkeeper is the funniest word
but do you also understand that i was
blackout drunk at seven in the morning
will you move into my home and become
the innkeeper
i got fired for a reason i wasn't in i
was an
out keeper and that reason is why i i'm
hiring you
all right we're good to go we need to
eat mexican food the second that we wrap
this episode
and that she does mean your pink taco
get it out pull it out of the hole all
right and this one will go in order guys
uh clockwise starting with esther say
one full sentence in spanish
i'm going to say a sentence that then i
will tell the history behind it
and that is from when i worked at johnny
rockets
and i would ask the guys in the back of
the kitchen
to give me a little more ice cream when
he made my oreo milkshake for me
and they would always tell me this has a
lot of calories esther be careful and i
said um
okay one point good annie i have a
theory that you've
the only thing you've ever done is
worked at johnny rockets i have a theory
nothing else has ever happened in your
life
there's been nothing else every story
you have happened at johnny rockets i'm
pretty sure that you even when you don't
tell us
okay um okay so this is my box i have a
little backstory for this too
um no tango pinocchio solomente la verga
chupame la verga
that's multiple but it goes together you
know it's like i couldn't pick one
uh i have no vagina only a penis
a suck my penis or chuba mela chile do
you say that when like guys like
when they're like and i'm like
um i throw a rock at them yes no i
that was in when i was in guatemala you
still have to do that
but um no i say that you know i worked
in kitchens
i you know i had a little
hangout time i had some beans and rice
with a lot of the uh
staff and stuff yeah i did a little
[ __ ] puppy
with the kitchen staffy staffy and a lot
of mexi mexi restaurants
but you had an ex-boyfriend yes my my
ex-boyfriend mark
who named himself [ __ ] marky he was my
mexican boyfriend we did
um we got married on ecstasy at a party
yeah
we're kind of married we our friend was
ordained and
and married us when we were on are you
married
we didn't sign anything so i don't think
i'm married but there's no signing but
in god's eyes they are
but yes and god is not going well
in god's ojos
infection can i guess you have an stv
yeah no oh i thought it was a bend over
and cough
no confess hold your
huevos do you have a sexual infection
yes esther
esther knows how to say that in every
language she learned it to johnny
rockets
did we win a sombrero did we [ __ ]
earn it or what well i did take four
years of spanish but i just
i can only it's and speaking of cannolis
we're hungry that was she said she
needed a taco immediately and the fact
you didn't throw that at her
makes me want to go george of course
you're gonna give me the mariachi hat
it's so cute you're gonna look like so
adorable
this is like turning me on wait are you
are those
fish earrings uh because see spirits
he's killing all the fish
or you're like i'm pro-fish murder
speaking of which um
valentine thomas's last post is so
illuminating really i think that you
should check it out
okay someone read it out loud to me
because you know i ain't reading
that sounded like a long caption i have
to say i trust my friend caroline has a
company
called fishwife where they sell tinned
fish do you want to like help her sell
it not wearing that
do you want to only wearing this
and there i trust like because i
actually am talking to her and she knows
all like it's all
like local and the fish are treated well
so i at least feel like that's a good
start but well that's not the tin fish
is
smaller fish like anchovy um sardines
and stuff like that
it's it's uh tuna and rainbow trout oh
okay
got it and i was gonna say like the best
thing you can do what i'm told
is um sardines like eat the small like
bait fish
does that make you nervous sardines are
a little bit scary to me i love sweets
because they're boiled they're bug
looking the skin and the tail it's all
they taste very good though have you
ever accidentally had one no
how would i accidentally eat one they're
in salads oh wait yeah and
she never would have come across um you
don't like season do you like caesar
salads because
the original recipe for caesar salad has
anchovies in the dressing
and the they're they are i will give you
that they are
disgusting there's like a hairiness to
them kind of feeling and
really but you like but i like them yes
but but the taste overrides the texture
wow my favorite meal is um
sticky white rice boiled egg and
sardines
that's like the best were you in prison
as a child and this is like
this that's a treat for me that's a
treat literally who calls it what is a
boiled egg like a hard-boiled
egg yeah it's not that's not how you say
it no it is
we don't like being demoted to refugees
again we should start just coming up
with things that are very normal
that's like against my like personal
constitution like i was saying
i was like this would be so fun and
bonding and i knew maybe someone
wouldn't want to do it
i can't you know what i i hate when
people are like did you know that when i
was little i
uh oh it's so annoying and then you're
like really and then they're like just
kidding i
i that pissed me off so much i okay and
it's as lo
and it's how long they go with it yeah
it's so frust
i was dating this guy it was like our
first or second date and we were we went
in his hot tub
and he was like um he was like yeah i
was
in billy elliot when i was a kid i was
on broadway and i was like
and he's kind of like small so i was
like and he can
i think he could sing i don't know so i
was like oh cool and i was like oh
that's awesome like that was that weird
to like
have to go to auditions and stuff and
then he just waited so long he was like
i just made that up
like i'm the idiot did i no then you
feel stupid right and now i'm dumb i'm
sorry i thought you were talented i
thought you might have been a talented
young man
i i know i i hate that quality in people
just and just like the hot tub was like
had the purple lights i'm like looking
at him with the purple lights
really full you're in a [ __ ] purple
light lit hot tub
talking [ __ ] to me annie you just spent
oh i did
10 days with your family for the first
time in a year and a half
wow it was so good what happened
we all [ __ ] it was like i missed their
body well was it like seeing your
parents after something it was
it was incredible so we went back todd
came with me we went
um brought random the plane he barked
from takeoff to landing
[Music]
it was an exercise for me to just not
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] what other people
think because there was nothing
it was a red-eye it was in the middle of
the night i mean it was
absolute hell and we had given him like
two of these pills that whitney's
boyfriend had prescribed him but so then
we get there it's like seven in the
morning my parents come and pick us up
so sweet little old people getting out
of their bed they came picked us up it
was like running it really was awkward
like i definitely like went in
deeper than my dad thought i was gonna
like i really
i came and i dipped him you really
tongued him down i tuned him down i mean
i was like for a joke maybe i should
because obviously i made todd film it
but um and then yeah i saw my mom went
back to the house
and then we immediately took their car
and we went to jersey and hung out with
todd's parents for
the first week was pretty much with
todd's parents and we went to the jersey
we went to the boardwalk
in the jersey shore and i got you guys
presents oh
fun todd's family's amazing by the way
asian mothers are like
i want to figure out how to bottle that
service and sell it because it was the
most amazing thing that's ever happened
to me
what was it like we walked in we came in
i took my my mom my mom and dad's car we
go over there
she cooked me pho my favorite i eat fall
like every day it was the best five ever
had
number one i eat it every day the best
five ever had the next day she made me
this like porridge soup that
she just made me every favorite food i
have from scratch
so delicious she kept trying to show me
how to make it and i was like i will
never
show your son i'm not he's gonna be
cooking
and then i realized like todd's like
completely just put on a whole thing to
win me over
his whole family's like ty's not gonna
cook for you like he does
and they're like i'm like oh god i have
like another six months of him doing
things for me
right right he's just done wait can i
interrupt i recently went to
dave's we stayed with his parents and
i have never felt so loved we got there
his mom was like so here's a bag
of a bunch of old happy meal toys for
you to go through
it's so sad that everyone knows that
your only experience has been at johnny
rockets
and so i got like all these old happy
meal toys from dave's mom
i was so happy it's like she was like i
knew i was saving them for some reason
i have a question for you guys when you
go to visit your
um spouse's parents what's the sleeping
arrangement
oh we had our own room we slept and is
it weird to
the living room no we slept in a room
together
in your old bedroom uh did you kiss in
my house
yeah we sleep in in my old bedroom do
you guys get kinky
no no i honestly i didn't feel like i
wanted to do that
no that does not like not that's not
appealing
also when we went in as far as like
presents and stuff
his mom had like this care package for
us with all this [ __ ] that was like
like eye masks and like peanuts and beef
jerky
and like slipper like it was just so
every
genre of thing and then a thing of candy
which
todd was we brought his parents edibles
that i have then ate
and todd was tackling me like i was like
don't let me eat any of the candy and
then i
mean he would turn around and i'd
immediately be like shoving jelly beans
it was like
just tackling me to the floor and um
yeah and then his aunt came over they
had like a late easter because his dad
had had kova during
their actual easter so that all the
babies came over his nieces and the
whole family
and uh his aunt gave us a chiropractor
it was like so many
wait his aunt his mom is layocean yeah
she's leo
nothing is better than asian hospitality
unbelievable
yeah because of being babies yes there's
no
culture that babies their babies more
like when my mom comes over
she's a little bit um you know she's she
has sort of like a very like
tough energy about her a little rock
salt we're not gonna a little rock salt
yeah
but if i ask her like mom like can you
brush my hair
she will do it for two hours she will
clean the whole house
she just knows what to do with it's just
the most comforting i just
get it in this way i never understood
and it was just
it was so nice and his mom kept like not
only would she make the food but she'd
be like
have more have more it would just be
like placed in front of you i mean which
it did get i started to be like listen
[ __ ] you're going to back the [ __ ] up
okay i've gained about 15 pounds in
48 hours does she have an accent yeah
she does did she call you aunt ani
um i don't know i don't remember how she
says my name
uh you're too busy slurping it down i'm
slurping
no but she can't she named todd todd but
she can't pronounce it she goes
like todd watch your pee pee like that
so
she and i and i was like i hung out with
the whole like for like five days
straight we were just having such a good
time
todd had work so he was just kind of
like editing in the corner and i was
just hanging out with his parents
and we just had the best time and i was
like you are so annoying like i don't
feel
at all bad at how annoying i'm with todd
like i'm gonna be more annoying
i can bust in the bathroom when he's
taking his [ __ ] forever now like there's
no
holds barred like she has raised a boy
that is
because you know how todd just his
temperament is like you could kind of
like just do anything around him yeah
just stay calm
because she is that fully and i've said
this to her face so and i mean this
would love
his own way really what is like what's
next but she's annoying and
like it's always just being helpful like
it's like i bought you these pants and i
bought i got you these things and here
are these clothes and yes i made you
this food eat this eat that do that did
you
you could get out a loan she works at
banks she'll she's like get a loan out
like it's all
did you do your taxes i'm like that's
the quicker word
they don't say taxes around it is tax
season it's a reminder to both of you
so you and todd are like real yeah we're
real people
i mean he's my assistant we haven't made
it a fish yet
we haven't kissed but then we went to
see my brother my brother just moved to
new jersey my older brother and we hung
out with
his sons and his wife is allergic to
dogs so we brought my parents
like old dog's crate so we could put him
outside and then it was too cold so
we put him in the basement and
immediately i feel so bad for my
sister-in-law because she's genuinely
allergic
everyone went down to the basement and
her two-year-old son just crawled right
into the crate
and just was locked in the crate and
would just cry when we took him out he
just loved being
a dog just all in the dog fluff
and stuff i did i liked that too it was
really of course you do i like to being
i was a dog named jacob when i was
little
i would bite people was that your name
tag at johnny rockets
esther you um really took in the spirit
of a dog
would you invite people yeah i thought i
was a dog i met this dog named jacob and
i just fell in love with him my favorite
movie was
finally have something in common was
your favorite movie 101 dalmatians
okay and so i just was like i'm a dog
now my name is jacob
i like you made people pet me
and um i would bite people and then i
would only eat out of bowls on the floor
and in fact like my sister recently
posted on facebook last year like oh
everyone check out my sister's comedy
special
and one of her friends wrote jacob
did you lift your leg to pee what did
you pee outside did you go
full like you know meisner or did you
i think i stayed peeing the normal did
you smell people's butt holes
probably uh kalaila nanny guess what a
jester was when this happened
um she was uh just finishing her second
year at johnny rockets
i wouldn't say um four
no seven i could call my mom and ask
because i'm a little bit old a little
bit too old
for sure when did jacob happen esther
should we call and ask
yeah call your mommy and ask mom
what um what age was i
when i was jacob the dog
you're on the podcast i'm sure you had
to be about four or five years old and
what did i do
you're sure it wasn't seven you didn't
like the milk bones
[Laughter]
what did i do you crawled around on all
fours
licking people and barking and you
lifted your leg to pee
all right miss you mr
[Applause]
do you always call your mom because your
dad doesn't always pick up
yeah i call the mom's phone yeah my
dad's phone is really old and
he's it's a jitterbug it's got two
buttons
calls and one relative
[Laughter]
oh my god wait so what's our present
okay so i got these at the jersey shore
for you and i decided to go
full jersey shore all right i got
i had these made i got you this
free sich and it's the situation
situation mike the situation is my least
favorite guy
good then it worked i loved probably
probably snooki yeah snooki is good i
should i mean
i wouldn't it honestly was like what
fits on the shirt
yeah because they're doing it but i went
to the actual place that they worked
on the show they worked at a t-shirt
shop on the boardwalk did you watch um
jersey shore
i will gladly wear that so i will take
um the sitch
all right that's for you i got myself
this one
it's paulie d and it says she's
definitely a stage five clinger
i can't believe that's not mine no no
yours is this one
i get to open it yeah reveal it it's
ronnie and it just says
wow
i don't even know if these are the
things they said or whatever it was just
do i do we wear them now doesn't matter
yeah i want to wear mine now
and i will tell you my parents were
there my parents came todd's mom made us
prime rib and was just
my parents were so happy because they've
nev they have not been out the whole
wait shut up kill i was changing
i don't want to look you didn't want me
to talk to distract
people from the fact that what bra is
that it's a dance skin one
oh i love dan's skin i think thank you i
think kyle and i have the same underwear
if anyone's interested
we do well we also have that two-person
underwear gonna have to put on at some
point
oh that's right we still have only fans
okay so then we go to boston and i see
my niece
and i surprised them in a way that is
beyond what i could have imagined okay
so
my baby niece is about to turn five and
then my
my my first niece is about to turn nine
okay they have a giant box because my
brother got some like litter box so
there's a giant
box waiting so it was perfect human size
so i think they're coming in from soccer
practice so i think i'll just
be in the box in the driveway and then
dana's gonna send them out to go like
move the box
so and it's something that she'd been
complaining about how big the
litter box was so this has been in their
their world
so i think instead of like them being
super terrified i'll give them a hint by
wearing my leopard print jacket that
they know i always wear and i'll have
that like showing
what if they like pulled out a gun and
shot you
[Laughter]
it would have been i mean i'm gonna do
this until they're 40 so
until i'm dead my last thing i pop out
of is going to be a casket
like surprise i'm not dead yet um but so
they
what i didn't think was that they
wouldn't associate me with the animal
print but an actual animal
so they come out of the car and they go
i have this all filmed
they go and they go to move the box and
it's heavy and i pop out
and my niece my baby niece she's so
like fight or flight scared like she was
out of soccer practice and then she was
in the [ __ ] jungle book like she
thought she was like
i thought it was a tiger she thought an
actual wild animal like
an experience most children will never
have in their lives
like only a nightmare she thought an
animal was lunging out to attack her
but then she immediately realized it was
me and they were so happy like
mind blown and then i knew my parents
were there too so i go
and they didn't know about randy either
so then they go in and there's another
surprise of the dog so my niece again
jumps like oh it's a dog and then they
go in and my parents
are hiding behind the curtains so then
they see their their legs and they just
when they like hugged my parents
everyone was crying it was like
oh it was just so good it was so fun and
then we were there for
like four or five days when you're all
your brothers both your brothers came
too no my older brother and his wife and
the boys had to stay in
new jersey but we'll get together soon
but it was just so fun
it was like crazy and we had a birthday
party because we missed everyone's
birthday parties and which is my parents
excuse to eat a cake so it was just a
giant cake and we
had a little smoke by the fire one night
had a great time
it was a dream come true getting high
with my dad and
eating children's food while they're
asleep is for their lunch the next day
is like something i thought i'd never
get to do again it was so fun i have a
question
do you feel like because there's so many
children in the family already
like because for me like i'm my dad's
only child so there's no grandchildren
so like there's a little bit of like
pressure but i feel like
he didn't want you that's true he
actually has actively told me that he
doesn't want grandchildren
but i i'm curious in your situation i
feel like i wouldn't feel any pressure
do you feel like oh it's taken care of
yeah i definitely don't feel pressure at
all because wow my older brother's two
sons and my twin brother has two
daughters it's like
and your mom never asks you or wow
my mom same with my mom she has never
pressured me once in fact she's just
like don't have them
are you serious and she's like i love
when moms get real and they're like
listen it ruins you
like it's [ __ ] done well she knows me
so well she's like i just know how you
love and that's just gonna be something
that's gonna cause you a lot of like
anxiety and pain
even the fish just abandoned yeah that
was really
i know but yeah she never has never
mentioned anything she's like
you have dogs it's enough what about to
your sister not at all
my sister is not having children she's
decided she's very firm about it
and she feels real real good about it
too yeah
yeah i don't feel good about that firm
decision yet but i i could go either way
but i do think i'll probably have kids
yeah but that's nice that you don't feel
any sort of pressure yeah no thank god
and i had
i was putting a lot of pressure on
myself for a while remember i was having
like a breakdown at the beginning of the
pandemic
because i was like it's taking away like
my time to make enough money to feel
comfortable to have kids and stuff i was
like
just another year gone my reproductive
covett stole the best years of my
reproductive life but look at what we
did instead
we had another kind of baby to a little
baby baby
baby podcast do you guys believe in
demonic possessions what
esther i will say this about you for
somebody who
is afraid of um crickets and things like
that
you are the most fearless person i've
ever met in regards to ghosts
and serial killers serial killers yeah
because when i
don't know that's cereal she likes
cereal
when we wanted to go visit the la bianca
house oh
remember where the um charles manson's
um
cronies had killed like the first family
i was terrified i was like this isn't a
good idea i don't want to go there i
don't want anything to like jump into my
being
oh and you were like it's funny yeah i
well when you say serial killers it's
like well i don't think at the la bianca
house like we're all gonna get stabbed
like i just didn't think like
i i doesn't strike twice like that i am
not afraid of
anything that is like to me i just call
it fake like
ghosts i don't believe in ghosts i don't
believe in vitamins that i don't believe
in
but in that regard you're so much
tougher than i will ever be because if
i've never admitted this out loud on a
on a show before but i
i cannot sleep in my own house alone i
have never and will never
i will i refuse i'll never if bobby goes
out of town you call theo
feels like i'm here girl flies from that
takes their head off
the squishy squashy over here that's my
theo impression
but but always i call my mommy i cannot
sleep
if and because you feel like there's
ghosts yes and i and it's so weird
because i'm an
atheist but i believe in these like
weird things that have just embedded
into my mind is it cultural
i don't know is it cultural yeah well my
sister is
and in fact every time it comes up my
dad and i
we like laugh our asses off like she
believes in ghosts like she's an
idiot like i just am not scared of it i
also grew up in a house where both my
grandparents died in that house
and i always just felt like you do have
that vibe though maybe
there are in you and that's why you're
this way i'm like you are there's a
grandparent in you
yes i'm like if there really are their
spirits or ghosts are here
like i'm their grandchild so i'm good
like
ghost i feel like ghosts like your
living grandparents don't like you so
well no they don't that's true
there's just um there's this guy he's
actually a
he's from harvard he went to yale
columbia and harvard
but he's a psychiatrist that's like too
much his name is richard
his gut his name is richard gallagher
and he
smashes pumpkins and let me tell you
when he smashes a watermelon
it's wild but he believes in demonic
possessions and the
church basically hires him to
tell them whether it is a mental illness
or a demonic possession he's able to and
the reason he believes this
is because he says i cannot explain
certain things he's like i'm a
practicing doctor and a physician he's
like the certain things i can't explain
is when all of a sudden someone speaks
perfect latin
and knows information that
has never been told to them before about
someone else in the room including
myself
okay i have to say that this guy is a
genius because he's probably the first
person to ever make money off the church
so good for him yeah i just i
put me in like the most haunted house
i will spend the night there by myself
like i just don't
as long as there's like security you
know i'm not afraid of spirits or demons
or anything like that
and i think that doctor is a quack
that's ridiculous
yeah and that's what people are like oh
he's he's getting
paid yeah dollars by the vatican or
something
it also but it just doesn't to me it's
like
what was the did you see the documentary
it was like the amazing jonathan i think
yes i've seen it
i really like that where he like
debunked all of these fake psychics and
stuff and
there's a netflix show now too that's
like something about spiritual
stuff and ghosts and stuff and it is a
really really ridiculous
i don't even like a movie where it's i
like movies a scary movie that's like
feels like it's about real stuff i it
has to be something that i think could
happen
i don't i'm not scared of ghosts are you
scared of ghosts
no i'm so sick of every podcast i go on
people like give a ghost story
are you [ __ ] what are we in third
grade i'm a [ __ ] ghost star and here
i am like
traumatized but you like killed chickens
for breakfast like i don't know what you
were up to over there
well you have a you had a hole but it's
it's
i feel as though just around the band
i'm gonna you know there's gonna be a
face or something there i think there's
energy like i don't think we die
like i think there's like energy that we
all become and stuff so i think like
there's that and i think all of our
ancestors are inside us
but it's just not i just am not i would
really
not want to be one of your ancestors
trapped inside you
i just i would really not you're like my
little anne frank in the end
i just would not want to be that just
like what is she up to what whatever
there's no way they're they're like me
i'm them no
and then that grandmother that hates you
it's because you're like her no
it's not no or her we're not
just like all of our ancestors we are
we're all the same thing
i think you can have some similarities
but you're not just like them like i'm
my sister and i are nothing alike my mom
and i
have like very little in common i'm
exactly like my dad that'll but like
my grandma and i are so different
there's no way are you exactly like your
mom
i'm a lot like my mom what it's crazy
how annoying my family is like they're
very the attention they need from people
working at dunkin donuts
is unmatched and it's never given the
attention is never given my mom's like
we're gonna give you a good rating right
now i'm like mom you don't know how to
rate this person by the way
are you like your relatives i'm a lot
like my dad
um but hard to tell because he was also
really old by the time i guess that's
why you have such heart problems
yeah physically um i'm absolutely
nothing like my mother
which is why there's it tends to be a
little contentious because except for
the bra
and the damn skin and also the fact that
she likes to
um she's a fitness queen but i didn't i
didn't
want to be a fitness person that [ __ ]
was just you know i had no choice
growing up so that we have in common but
she's she's the best i love her
i love my mommy so much but i think we
obviously are way more like one parent i
mean i'm so much like my dad
we were just laughing my dad was killing
he had so many good lines like we were
in the car and my mom where this is like
me was just calling all of her friends
on speaker phone
on this car right todd was driving so
tired and just had to it was the exact
experience of me just like facetiming
and calling people all day
and my mom's just calling her friends
i'm like hey we're on a car ride my
here with scott annie's here and todd
annie's boyfriend's here say hi we gotta
go
see you later and then she was like who
should we call next my dad's like the
police there's about to be a homicide
like they're just like so many my dad
was just like and i was like this is
exactly where i get it
it's like the same he just made me laugh
so hard we just had such a good time
wow that sounds so fun what i wanted to
say the moral of the story of why i
brought that up esther of like demonic
possessions is because like
like i think that from a distance all
i'm saying is you can't
judge a girl every time someone says
i love that song is that vanessa
williams no it's brett midler
bette midler from a distance um don't
judge a girl
by her lack of desire to eat crickets
because i genuinely think you're low-key
the bravest person i've ever met just by
virtue of having like no fear in regards
to like
ghosts and stuff like you've never every
time i talk about it you're like that's
not real who cares
i'm like crying about it she did think
the dead crickets were gonna
jump on that's true i thought the dead
crickets were demonic
i um i think it's because i was raised
absolutely with no religion at all so
that stuff is just not on the table for
me i'm i'm envious though
i'm so envious of the fun it must be to
like feel the fear
of ghosts and stuff it's not fun or like
to believe in heaven sounds nice it does
sound pretty sweet i'm like oh it's
awesome
but yeah you i'm surprised you don't
like to skydive and stuff why don't you
just scare yourself
that's the same as being scared of
ghosts it's just different type of
adrenaline
that is like so not i mean
because i'm that's the thing is i'm
really scared of a lot of stuff well if
you believed in heaven would you want to
because you'd be like if i die
like growing up all my cousins would
always go like ice fishing and go on the
atv
and stuff and i would always stay back
and say you on an atv is
you look like the little like bobble
head i would like stay back
and sit with my great grandma while
everyone all the cousins went and had
fun
and then we could never have like an
outdoors episode of ice fishing
esther will be hanging out i'm a
grown-up now we'll get you something we
gotta get a really elderly woman to sit
with you
i think that'd be so fun if we just go
in our our camos out into the wilderness
i would do that you know i can't get
down i'll do it you'll hang
can we just clear i'm desperate for a
field trip okay
i'm ready for vegas i will even go to
the outdoors i want to go to palm
springs we'll just take her to like an
outdoor mall we're like we took you to
the grove
i want a field trip with this wait do
you remember when we went to the grove
and they were doing extra yeah outside
esther and i in the very beginning of
our friendship
when we were little babies at the comedy
store we went to the grove one day and
it was mario lopez and maria menounos
we're doing extra live out and we
we're trying to get maria nunez to talk
to us so badger dog with her and esther
going
i like your dog and she's like thanks i
loved her wait
i know you read her book right you were
obsessed with maria yeah i don't know
maria menounos is awesome
she's like a real girls girl like gives
good advice
she's smart and cool i just love her she
just seems so indestructible
she also loves wrestling she's like
she's like a girl's girl but also like
yeah she does it all oh yeah she she
does it all her book is great
she taught me my favorite thing i
learned from her book was like you can
just go to target and buy like 25 white
washcloths for
like spend like eight dollars and then
you roll them up in your bathroom and it
feels like you're in a spa
i love being fancy for cheap so i'm like
thank you i thought you were gonna say
and she taught you to tie-dye
oh my god she sucks she owes you
everything
no ass i do miss your um bad tie-dye
your bad diet was so funny because it
was so is there such a thing as bad
tie-dye
yes esther found a way to make
everything like mud
and period standing and one should go do
you like this one that one's good she's
like dave did it every time
every time i was like that oh my god i i
am so
bad at tidying she does yellow it just
looks like pee like it looks like the
shirt was like
crumpled up and someone peed on it
that's why i've outsourced it and now a
factory
a die house does it because i'm so bad
good vision poor execution thank you
i'm that's me with everything she's a
delegator
i'm a dictator but do you know that that
is
actually like a skill of successful
entrepreneurship
is being able to delegate and being able
to match your vision with people who you
know can execute your vision
so props to you esther you are an
entrepreneur thank you and even if
someone didn't want to work with you you
would
keep them annie bend over and spread
your butt it looks
actually does look almost tie-dyed my
[ __ ] because from brown to a lighter
color it's really
um we should do a sleepover by esther
episode so we can get some
i will bring you some when i get it's
coming soon and also
can we have an actual sleepover yeah
yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait who's-house
i mean obviously it's not a motel esther
and i are dying to get out of her own
why do you think she wants oh wait
you guys i forgot to tell you when i
came back from my trip we came back at
night
two day nights ago i come in there's
more construction in my apartment than
has ever existed like we've had
construction since the day
covet started and it was way worse like
the whole front of the building is just
abort like it looks like it got boarded
up for the [ __ ] riots
and it was like and i know it wasn't all
right but right in my neighborhood it
was 100 ryan's
but so like it was completely boarded up
and there was
they had dug up the street in front of
it like it was comical but only
in front of our building and we're like
we got to get out of here we looked at
each other as we're walking we're like
this is it we're done so then i walk in
and i get our mail
and there's a letter from the irs and
i'm like oh no
oh no it's gonna be bad and then i was
like don't be negative
you're fine nothing's hard that's my new
mantra nothing's hard i was like just
open it and be positive
and i opened it and it was an unclaimed
tax return of six thousand dollars
went deposited went and checked out an
apartment or we're moving to
venice beach in two days you're moving
yeah wait that's where we sleep over
there yeah
you have to watch our new yes okay we
can bring our rollerblades and maybe we
can like rollerblade together on the
boardwalk
esther i love this is my idea of esther
rollerblading we're on rollerblades and
she's just wearing the wrist guards
you're moving in two days yes it's so
cute it's like we picked the one bedroom
because the sun is so nice like it's
like
lighting's everything i would take a
smaller well
over a big really dark yeah i hate like
poorly lit we get it wednesday items
we know you don't need to do that so
funny because where i live there's so
much sun and i'm always like
i said look i literally look at my
neighbors with trees blocking the sun
for them and i'm like
i'm like i jealous you and bobby this is
what i wanted
your basement dwellers yeah you guys are
basement dwellers when i first met bobby
he had aluminum foil
in every single window to block out
crazy
you know you have money you could just
get blackout curtains he's like what are
those
he's like i bought them at a black house
but there's
there was this experiment done in france
where like 40 people
went into this cave and lived there um
with no clocks
no nothing basically it's like they
couldn't it was
a way to like see how people um manage
themselves their emotions and what they
did
in a dark place with no indication of
what time of day it was
and i was like this they should have
gotten bobby for this or you now esther
yeah it's like your dream come true to
just not know time and just live in a
dark place
oh but not knowing time sounds fun i
feel like you are bad at time
is it hard when it's the arms no bobby
can't read to
each other
wait bobby only wears digital watches
because he doesn't know what he's the
only reason you
because you just had people tell you
you're like can someone tell me what the
time is no i can read time you [ __ ]
i why
because i don't look at i mean we all
have the time on our phone
oh here here it is 40 days in isolation
look how happy they are french people
are weird and you know what like
two-thirds of them said they wanted to
stay in there longer
they also used to be oh so that wasn't a
new part for them
they're like we already smell this joint
up i just can't imagine being stuck in a
cave i could imagine if it was like my
sister and i
but would 40 people that i didn't know
what about just me and theo ew i don't
like that you're
the theo no i she's he's kalila and
you're a theo
i think he has a he's a has a funny and
his energy is really cute
he's very not like uh that's why i love
him like yeah
he's not part of him that's like it like
that masculine intimidation
he doesn't have that he's just a
sweetheart like i just want to hold him
yeah don't again he's gonna be like she
wants to hold me no like cradle swaddle
him like i want to swaddle lester that's
the same energy
esther's like wait what do you mean you
don't have you guys ever heard of those
like um
retreats where it's like a 10-day silent
retreat yes i always want to do
i know i'd get kicked out so funny they
thought of you doing
can you imagine i would you're not
allowed to make eye contact i want to go
with you
i bet you do you try to distract me how
many days
how many days do you think you'd last i
would do the whole thing because i
like i'm competitive with myself like
that but i would hate it but what do you
do are there things to do no you do
walking meditations they feed you
journaling and stuff yeah but you're not
allowed to make eye contact another to
write
yourself you're not allowed to write
either so it's just like inward travel
oh that's that's hard i really i was
very much looking into it and then i
just broke up with my boyfriend i was
like every time i'm like
maybe i should decide my treat i'm like
no i just need a breakup
it's like also whenever i'm into tarot
cards it's like just break up with him
he doesn't like you
every time i'm into anything that's like
ghosts and stuff it's like because i'm
about to get ghosted
i will say that i feel like when we
started the podcast we had a different
idea of what it was gonna be
like we thought we were gonna i feel
like get into more
politically like hot buttony topics and
fight
which i still feel like we might but i
don't feel like it's i feel like what
you said the other day i
were like half mukbang half mukbang half
gang bang bang bang yeah like i feel
like we are weirdly more sexual
and more foodie like than we thought
we're more like
it's like sweet and savory is what i
feel like yeah we're less
criminal than we thought yeah we're just
weird little beings
we are not um we are not a slasher movie
we just have a really
strange friendship yes which is why
i think now this is just my vote i think
that
we should have a name change and a
rebrand really
it's pre like merch so i think this
would be right
the merch is like the because people are
demanding merch
but that's like i feel like that's when
it's official so we have to like get it
right before people are repping it
do you also remember when clayton was
doing our hair to do our photo shoot and
he was like it's too negative oh he
hated the name yeah he hates the name
what are our options guys i i know that
well let me throw it out there esther
you hated this one but
is [ __ ] beach back on the table i i'm
not
a [ __ ] it's so funny that i would say
you're uh
like i maybe come off as the but for
real you're the biggest [ __ ]
no i'm not like well we have i can have
30 seconds of more bloodbath for one
moment
why it's not it the reason [ __ ] beach
can't happen but [ __ ] beach was more
like bitching like it wasn't like
we were right and also i don't think i
have [ __ ] it's not like
yeah three old horses three horses might
look a little cuter
on my chest that's bloodbath or old
spermies
i love i love um two words that i love
together are blood honey
because i think it's a little dark and
sexy and mysterious i don't i don't
think that's like we know what that is
um
what are what are some ideas you guys i
like blood honey bad blood
bad blood i like bath friends it's
crazy what does that even mean i don't
it's what she calls her
duckies your rubber duckies
sleepover by annie kalila and esther
yeah
oh my god she's like buy my sleepover
brand
the podcast like naming the show was
really hard that's why
we settled on something we didn't all
love yeah and dave hated it too
oh yeah dude i don't remember or he was
like i think he just hated us
yeah well we didn't have um what was the
potato when we had wild potatoes wild
potatoes
that's not happening wait do you
does bobby like bloodbath bobby loves
bad blood
he thought the whole time our show was
called bad blood he didn't realize it
was bloodbath
he was like how's the how's bad blood
going i was excited it's not the name
but
i think there's some things we have to
think about okay we have to think about
one like what's gonna look pretty merch
style but also
like what do we call our fans like we've
never came up with a new name and stuff
like that
yeah the bad blood heads the
bath heads esther's just very anti-blood
i think
i like bath more than i like blood but
that doesn't mean
i'm against blood that means are you
into wild potatoes
no are you i loved i loved wild potatoes
i was so
sold on wild potatoes when we were
talking about this a year ago
we had been we were at our maybe 172
right of trying to fight that was my our
hail mary i was like [ __ ] it it's wild
potato do you want wild potatoes
i want blood i want blood honey you like
blood honey i like blood honey
um well plenty to think about what do
you guys think
i want to say i'm not surprised that
this is where we are are we taking
suggestions
yeah i think it could be something that
our fans can probably
you know they know us you guys know us
better
here's the one thing that it has to look
good with it has to look good
on merchandise it has to look cute it
has to exude
a weird 70s vibe yes um
think um charles manson's uh
those three girls um those three little
devils
that did his work for him but like cute
and devilish that's the thing
right but um so we'll leave that up to
you
and then maybe we can come up with the
best the 10 best ones
and then we'll decide from there but we
are officially
are we officially rebranding that i
think we're officially on the hunt
for an awesome name right i'm happy
about this no i'm excited yeah
i don't think any of us love the name to
begin with i
loved it but i don't find that it fits
what we are
you loved it and then immediately the
first actually
tweet the first fan art we had was the
blah blah blah it made me uncomfortable
well also i just remembered she was like
i just don't like blood makes me
uncomfortable and then literally like
one second later
you know what i take it back i like it
because i'm used to it now
but i'm remembering that when we all
somewhat agreed on it
then you guys like move forward forward
with it and in my head i was like
did we really agree like i was like i'm
not a hundred percent sure but then like
i got used to it
but i was not ready for that to happen
again anyway guys
blood honey george do you have a name
that you like uh baby slugs
baby slugs oh or just
slugs sexy slugs because slugs is like
very close to [ __ ] too that's funny
slug sperm i don't know
like slugs guys she likes slugs and
sperms but
but blood and honey bothers her but i
don't know why but i i could be into it
i could be
the only reason i like that is because
it feels
like the vibe the part of bloodbath that
was the vibe i liked
yeah i don't like what it exudes yeah
oh my god you guys her feet aren't
touching the ground again it's so funny
i like when people when we get up and
it's and people are like she really is
little i'm like it's this is how i feel
every time i see esther
i've known her my half my life and every
time i see her i'm shocked
so shall we shall we right off into the
sunset we're gonna ride off into the
sunset nameless
once again but i feel like this is a
rebirth
and i feel like this is a great
opportunity to really tap into who we
are
oh we should call it after birth
plus then placenta like the live song
so offended by that i know i was
offended by that i remember the video of
that too do you remember the music video
oh yeah it just fell thank you so much
for listening
to whatever this was and whatever this
shall be
i've been esther this is annie and
that's kalylah and you guys
you know we want you to subscribe like
this video and put a
comment down for the algorithm and tell
us what you think we should name the
show
thank you for listening see you guys
next time just where you want to be
[Music]
you